enough we're not going to see blitz  today  not even amazon and no blitz but there  must be banter blitz at 8 pm no  8 pm but maybe we can we can do a bunter  since  for people to wait it would be desperate  it was a joke oh yeah i was hoping we  could  oh yeah you know i'm very ill yeah i  know you're very in  and the wolf yeah trying to prolong the  game to be honest  it's uh it's very hot in place so  and i'm walking every day now for  uh i don't know 10 days  and it's kind of world rico though  yeah here another professional decision  yeah  yes penco decides to simplify  leave duboff with no pawns and yes pinko  moves on  to the next round the  19 year old with a very solid  performance  doesn't seem like a young player no he's  just a well-rounded  professional tough  obviously this match on equal footing  but yes you can go previous